et bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8
les invités chaque jour rendez vous avec
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département des yvelines et pour
débuter la semaine vous entendrez
nicolas dupont aignan le député
président de debout la france est venue
dans les yvelines présenté son programme
c'était à rambouillet un choix loin
d'être anodin hubert védrine entend
mettre le monde au défi c'est le nom de
son nouvel ouvrage l'ancien ministre
socialiste était lui aussi dans les
yvelines
mais un versailles et puis laurent
brunelle chargée de programmation pour
les spectacles du château de versailles
nous présentera la saison 2016 2017
on débute donc par de la politique et
nicolas dupont aignan qui était en terre
yvelinoise pour sa dernière réunion
publique il a choisi rambouillet une
circonscription qui est actuellement
occupé par le député du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson
également candidat vous le savez à la
primaire de la droite et du centre
un choix pas si anodin vous allez
l'entendre le chef du parti debout la
france et évoque également revenu sur
son programme l'interview est menée par
nicolas landry jean frédéric poisson est
un des rares républicains du parti des
républicains avoir compris larnack de
l'union européenne telle qu'elle est
construite et de le dire et je l'en
félicite
maintenant est-ce qu'il va gagner la
primaire je ne sais pas si la gagne et
bien bravo
si la paire eh bien j'espère qu'il
votera pour moi parce que je vois pas
comment il peut voter pour des gens qui
défendent exactement l'inversé de ce
qu'il défend d'abord je souhaite que les
communes gardent leur liberté et je suis
hostile à ces immenses communauté
d'agglomération communautés de communes
qui vont être la prime à la bureaucratie
et à la dépense publique
je crois que tout ce qu'ils
s'administrent de près sur le terrain et
coûte toujours moins cher qui est des
économies il est faux
en revanche ce qui est choquant c'est
que l'état a transféré aux communes de
nouvelles charges par exemple la réforme
absurde des rythmes scolaires et en même
temps il réduit les dotations aux
communes
alors moi je voudrais qu'on m'explique
comment on fait moi j'ai fait des
économies dans ma ville et là les
dotations je les ai assumé comme
beaucoup de mères mais il ya un moment
où on va arriver à loos
on y arrive et c'est pourquoi je crois
qu'il faut être prudent dans les
prévisions de diminutions de dépenses
publiques car eux il faut plus qu elles
augmentent il faut essayer de faire
diminuer mais il faut pas non plus
promettre n'importe quoi je veux qu'on
maintienne le département je suis
hostile aux grandes régions qui ne sont
que des copinages et du gaspillage et je
crois au département je veux d'ailleurs
en france regrouper certains
départements car j'estime que avec 70
départements
on pourrait très bien administrer la
france ait rien n'interdirait rien
n'interdirait d'avoir les présidents de
départements où les vice présidents qui
travaille au niveau régional ensemble et
c'est pourquoi je suis pour la
suppression des conseils régionaux je
pense qu'il faut d'abord relancer
l'initiative privée qu une fois que la
machine économique va se relancer alors
on sera en capacité de réduire la
dépense publique mais si vous réduisez
la dépense publique d'un coup en
arrivant je voyais certains candidats -
cinq cent mille emplois suppressions d
emplois aidés ce sont des emplois qui
permettent à des jeunes et à des
personnes au chômage de reprendre le
travail ce absurde
j'ai appris que la société du grand
paris qui construit ce métro qui va
dépenser des dizaines de milliards
d'euros de notre argent
le vôtre le mien l'argent du
contribuable et bien cet argent serait
attribuée à des entreprises étrangères
de bâtiment et travaux publics
ça veut dire quoi des travailleurs
détachés ça veut dire que l'argent des
français sert à nourrir l'emploi à
l'étranger
c'est scandaleux donc moi je fais une
proposition c'est que 75 % de dépenses
de des commandes publiques des
collectivités locales aille à des
entreprises qui fabriquent en france
l'académie des sciences morales des arts
et des lettres de versailles feu
et sa rentrée solennelle la semaine
passée pour cette première conférence
l'académie recevait à l'ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères hubert védrine l
ex conseiller de françois mitterrand a
parlé de son dernier ouvrage le monde au
défi
il a développé notamment son idée de géo
écologie écouter dont les relations
internationales mon prend en compte
essentiellement la question de puissance
politique économique militaire les
valeurs la démocratie des choses comme
ça petit à petit la dimension écologique
de plus en plus fortes on l'a vu avec la
négociation conclut à paris sur la coupe
21 c
c'est sans précédent que l'ensemble des
pays du monde surmontent leur approche
particulière leurs contraintes pour se
mettre d'accord sur un programme aussi
ambitieux j'aime bien ça va aller plus
loin et que progressivement
on va juger le comportement des pays
dans le monde pas uniquement donc sur la
politique et d'économie mais aussi là
dessus les jeunes des pays qui ne
joueraient pas le jeu
cap avoir signé des engagements
concernant le climat l'écho diversité la
réduction des nuisances ou la protection
des espèces animales protégées loyer et
qui ne joueraient pas le jeu après
seront désignés montré du doigt
récemment la procureur de la cour pénale
internationale a annoncé qu'elle allait
se saisir elle même des crimes
écologiques
donc je crois qu'une évolution et que
progressivement ça va influencer la
géopolitique qui ont une diminution de
compétitivité écologique une notion de
crime écologique contre l'humanité etc
etc
ça sera jamais le
le premier enjeu ni le seul enjeu y aura
beaucoup d'anges et en même temps il ya
des enjeux de sécurité de pouvoir la
capacité militaire des pays ratures des
zones de conflit comme le moyen-orient
aujourd'hui donc je ne dis pas que ça va
devenir le seul élément bien sûr mais
progressivement ça va entrer en danger
et on va d etat
colabor contribuer de façon positive à
l'écologisation de l'économie de la
société pour interrompre le compte à
rebours écologique et toutes ces menaces
et que d'autres jouent pas le jeu
donc c'est revenir 13 éléments
importants sera pas le seul élément il y
en aura d'autres et ça n'existait pas
avant
imaginons que la chine ne réduisent pas
du tout le trafic qui fait qu'en afrique
on tue des éléphants et des rhinos pour
leurs cornes et pour le pôle ivoire et
que la chine dit je m'en fiche vraiment
bizarre et des années c'est au début on
se dit il ya d'autres problèmes sur plus
important et le développement est une
chose comme ça et au bout d'un moment
une partie de l'opinion mondiale de la
chine se conduit mal ça va devenir un
élément de pression sur la chine alors
aujourd'hui on peut rigoler en aidant
les chinois ils s'en fichent ils sont
tellement puissants c'est pas tout à
fait vrai ces deux prises le président
chinois
elle vient d'annoncer un renforcement de
la répression contre les trafics de
vendredi voire prohibée donc chaque sa
belle et très vite en fait est que ça va
entrer dans le champ de la discussion
mondial pendant longtemps sur l'édition
de climat la chine disait ça nous
concerne pas on n'est même pas sûr qu'un
échange d'un deuxième ancien change dans
ce cas pas de faute c'est de la faute
des pays qui ont fait la révolution
industrielle et donc c'est à vous de
payer en euros c'est ce qu'ils disaient
avant paris puis au bout d'un moment
c'est devenu tellement préoccupant pour
les chinois eux mêmes en chine à buxy
mondiale mais la pollution poyet et il
ya tellement d'énervement des
internautes chinois qui sont quand même
500 millions que même le régime chinois
kepa régime
autoritaire et qui obligé de tenir
compte de sa population est obligée de
bouger
propos recueillis par nicolas kirilow
vide sculpture à présent depuis
maintenant huit ans le château de
versailles propose de re découvrir de
grandes oeuvres classiques plusieurs
lieux de la demeure du roi soleil
accueille les artistes opéra royal
galerie des glaces ou encore la chapelle
écoutez laurent brunner c'est le
directeur est de versailles château
spectacle nous parle à de la
programmation pour cette nouvelle saison
c'est au micro de mélanie poquet d'abord
c'est la huitième saison ça paraît pas
mais ça fait bientôt huit saisons qu'on
a réouvert cet opéra royal en 2009 et
c'était un moment important parce que il
ya une maturité à ce moment ci on s'est
présenté à la fois des grandes oeuvres
du répertoire à certains moments les
quatre saisons de vivaldi la cinquième
symphonie de beethoven le requiem de
mozart donc des choses qui sont on va
dire le grand répertoire est par
ailleurs proposé au public des
redécouvertes complète des choses très
différentes et qui à chaque fois sont
redonné avec les meilleurs interprètes
alors c'est raphaël pichon c'est
christophe rousset et qui sont donnés
dans un cadre d'exception
à
l'opéra royal vous avez le droit d'y
venir vous ne savez pas qu'il existât
vérité puisque ce bâtiment n'a pas de
façade sur la ville il était vraiment
l'opéra intérieure du château de
versailles réservé à des soirées très
exceptionnel du temps de louis saez
aujourd'hui chacun d'entre nous peut
venir dans ce lieu magnifique qui était
le cadre du mariage de louis saez
marionnettes tout de même ces choses
extraordinaires
je fais un aveux complets je ne
programme jamais les choses où j'ai
l'impression je l'emmerdé
parce que je sais que public il va être
comme moi voire peut-être plus que moi
avoir tendance ne connaissant pas
l'oeuvre à se dire bon alors ça ça ne
m'intéresse pas je veux au contraire des
projets qui sont pétillants qui me
redonne envie d'écouter de la musique
chaque fois que j'allume et c'est le cas
pour raphaël pichon pour beaucoup
d'autres interprètes des plus célèbres
william christie john eliot gardiner
dans le messie de haendel ou le mec défi
cap de balle vraiment des monuments et
parce qu'on joue aussi à la chapelle
royale
les interprètes sont jeunes sébastien
daucé valentin tournet raphaël pichon
gaëtan jarry tout ça sont des gens non
seulement jeunes non plus pour la
presque tous les noms de jeunes cités
c'est des gens qui sont nés où habiter
où habite versailles
c'est pas pour ça qu'on les programmes
se serait pas une prison heureusement
mais je crois beaucoup en le fait qu' il
ya autour de ce château à un moment des
ondes qui incite des musiciens en herbe
des jeunes à se dire on va essayer quand
même allons-y elle pousse un peu va plus
loin et ce plus loin la boutique un jour
on leur dit venez jouer ici qui est pas
le lieu pour des petites musiques et des
petits musiciens met à nu pour les
grandes musiques et les grands musiciens
la logique c'est qu'à un moment quand
ils font des programmes qui ont du sens
dans la chapelle royale dans l'opéra ou
dans la gueule des glaces vient y les y
présente et je crois que c'est ça qui
compte
retrouver le sens des lieux avec des
programmes artistiques et aussi du
ballet est un peu de théâtre on va
refaire à nouveau son bourgeois
gentilhomme que j'aurais vu peut-être 50
fois en cinq ans ou six ans maintenant
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
aujourd'hui replay sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme et puis
est nouvelle édition demain 18h45 en
attendant les programmes se poursuivre
sur notre
thème